es que tenemos hecho de las en sus redes
sociales lo llaman el viejito con cariño
pero tras bambalinas son estos 13
jóvenes los que han catapultado la
campaña política de rodolfo hernández a
diario rompen paradigmas las ideas se
construyen entre dos no salen sólo de mí
ni salen sólo de ellos incluso son del
ingeniero a veces él a veces hay cosas
que dice porque no se hace un texto con
tal cosa es como kaká el éter le
aterrizamos las ideas y lo y lo
construimos entre todos como no son
especialistas en marketing político
manejan la campaña como si se encargarán
de vender un producto la imagen del
ingeniero lo dota de valor digamos que
de todas las estrategias y tácticas que
nosotros hemos utilizado en redes
sociales con otro pero con otro
personaje con otro con otro candidato
tendrían que ser otra vez realmente él
es el protagonista de todo es muy muy
muy comunicador
y su candidatura ya es una marca los
bumangueses son sus mayores consumidores
en la capital de santander al noreste de
colombia
muchos son fanáticos lo siguen desde que
fue alcalde a pesar de un mandato
marcado por tres suspensiones
el ingeniero formó su fortuna y su
reputación en el sector inmobiliario
para jairo grimaldos arquitecto de su
constructora hg el político y el
empresario son dos caras de la misma
moneda es sobradamente medieval esta es
lo más sencillo así como son campañas
simple y sencillo a pocos kilómetros de
bucaramanga en la plaza central de
piedecuesta su ciudad natal se exhibe
ese minimalismo
esta casa modelo es una de sus promesas
miles serían entregadas a campesinos en
toda colombia
el proyecto ilusiona
pero propuestas como ésta le han valido
el adjetivo de populista mientras que el
ex concejal jon claro lo califica de
mentiroso en su estudio sobresalen las
pruebas de su versión sobre el día en
que hernández lo agredió físicamente
pero más allá de la mediática cachetada
claro cuestiona su famoso discurso
anticorrupción sea el único candidato
que está siendo acusado por corrupción y
que va en un proceso de juicio oral que
muy pronto él lo atenderá entonces se
contrapone si estoy luchando contra la
evolución porque estoy siendo
investigado y acosado 'tik tok' el
empresario e ingeniero los componentes
de una fórmula que rompe con la política
tradicional
y por la que rodolfo hernández apuesta
para llegar a la presidencia